big bad Johnny there is only now because
if you remember he had cancer and that
was like a last year and he's you know
keep the bucket by now but he's back as
a reanimated corpse array for him and as
you know the primary interest for EMEA
corpse is making sure you've got enough
money for the future so anyway he's a
setup
it starts off fairly normal and then it
starts to depart off and I might
actually grabbed a question Petofi so
that I can give you the right questions
certainly he's out begins the johnny is
investing $100 start of every month
okay the interest these guys three
percent per annum but is getting paid up
monthly which is kind of normal right so
three percent per annum
what is that work out soon when you
divide by twelve so you get point two
five percent per month okay so far so
good now I think one of the on the
earlier parts of the question yeah well
let's get an expression for a of M after
where n is you know the amount of months
to be going and what's the amount he's
got at the end of the month okay so he's
put in his deposit every month okay and
then he um he gets the interest at the
end okay so let's see how family you are
with this by now you guys know that what
I would want hourly do is I build this
from scratch I would say a1 is gonna be
this and then a2 will be that plus more
and so on and then I would build it up I
generally feel like doing three steps
enough to see the path okay
after you've got a few steps you built
it up from scratch then you generalize
okay but let's see if we can now
generalize off the bat okay so how does
this work what he's gonna have is every
month a hundred dollars is gonna go in
okay every month every month every month
so I'm gonna stick one hundred at the
front because you remember if every term
has a hundred on it then I can take that
as a factor out okay now then what
happens next each different amount one
hundred dollars all right is gonna have
a different amount of interest on it
right based on how long it's been in so
the first hundred dollars you put in
will have the most
interest then the next one will have one
lot less and then one lot less than that
and so on okay so what kind of series am
I going to have in here
well the oldest one the first lot of a
hundred dollars right he's gonna have
1.25 that's one lot of interest how many
Lots are you gonna have
well after M months you'll have that ^ m
so just thinking about it this is the
first 100 dollars and how much interest
it's got the next one is going to have
one less so to be n minus one okay and
so on until the end okay now the amount
of $100 they'll last one he puts in just
before we take the anthem out okay how
much interest will the hammer on them if
he puts your money on the side of the
month and he gets interested the end of
the world
how many lots of interest will he have
just the one right so I suppose if I put
a couple more at the end I've got one
point four to five squared and then the
very last one would be that okay so what
I would say is this here is the GP which
I want to it's a geometric progression
so I can take the sum of it right I've
got my hundred at the front and then
what's the formula for the sum of a GP
well a at the front right and because
your R is greater than one so I'm going
to put our first so this is our the N
minus 1 followed by - it's a fasiq bit
so let's have a look I can think about a
from either either direction okay I can
think about this is my a or this is my a
conventionally which we choose this one
right so I'll say one point five there's
my eight going from right to left
what's the common ratio what's getting
bigger by that same amount right so one
r-25 power n minus 1 all over Oh
- once 0.05 ok now I think the first
power question was sure that that's
equal to this I think this is what the
numbers come out so if you punch it into
your background
okay is that all right so that's the
first bit then I think they asked you to
solve
ok how many months as in what will M be
to get to a certain amount because
$3,000 or something with that so you get
a certain amount of months that's all
pretty textbook if you guys are okay
with that what I'm interested in with is
the next part of the question before I
get to that and read it to you I just
want to draw your attention to this
again I said we could think of as a GP
from either direction okay so how it
worked if I thought of this is the first
term hmm I have my hundred out the front
and then my a would not be 1.25 what
would it be
it'll be 1.0025 ^ and that would be my
first term now that changes a few things
in here doesn't it okay because my ratio
will no longer be 1.0025 what will it be
it'll be it'll be bet that I'm dividing
as I go from left to right I am dividing
by that so I could say it's one point
over to five to the power of minus one
okay now since I actually have to raise
that to the power of n that's gonna be -
it is that okay okay now then there's a
minus one and what happens on the bottom
it's I minus one
yes so 1.0025 it's the power of minus
one minus one
okay now does this work this is true
does this is this equivalence while we
work that before there's a workout
people are sure how would we verify
whether this and this were the same
thing well not because they look pretty
different at the moment what would you
do you should have two alternatives
you could sub some values you putting an
end equals blah or you know this one and
see what it's equal to that and see if
you get the same thing out okay I think
that would work
a better way probably would treat a deal
with the numbers okay how could I
simplify this to get close up just
something like that I can do some
expansion here right because I've got
numbers with on the same base okay so
for instance on the top here what would
happen this 1.25 to the N and this 1.25
to the power of minus M what would they
become when I put them in yellow for
instance okay let's just take a value of
n if I said 2 cubed x to the minus 3
would that be well that'll be 2 cubed
divided by 2 cubed right so that pot
should be 1 is that ok now what happens
to spit on the end it's 1.0025 it's at
the end okay then I have this on the
bottom I'm still not there yet what must
I do
I don't have to multiply by something
right what should i multiply by yeah
because I want to get rid of this
negative index right so if I multiply
everything here by one point zero two
five and this by 1.0025 see how we go
it's on the top I've got one point four
two five okay so far so good what
happens to the denominator what happens
when I multiply that first two by one
point / - 5 becomes one and then this
one becomes one point five I'll be close
enough yet I think we are right can you
see the equivalence between this and
this all that guy is a factor of minus
one that's the difference if I multiply
that minus one minus one this turns
around and this turns around and I'm
back to where I started so everything's
cool okay now the reason why I point
that out is because it looks weird
having it out a with ends in it okay but
you're actually going to need that to
solve the next bit so why don't you join
us down I'll give you the important
details okay